so you can hear me right now
so I will talk about pigeons like
tracking pigeons with Python and OpenCV
today and first I would like to
introduce myself I'm Nestle honey adesh
and I studied biology in Turkey as a
bachelor then later a bachelor I decided
to go on Academy then I studied
environmental science which was
combining like like botanic ENSO later
together but after finishing all my
lectures on my like proposal time I was
thinking if I want to go on like working
unrelated topic topics then the animal
behavior or if I want to like switch my
topic totally and go somewhere else and
at least do my master thesis about the
animal behavior then I decided to move
to Germany and for my master thesis and
after my master thesis my department
offered me a PhD positions now I'm the
PhD researcher at Weill psychology
department in boham in terminating the
name of the universities or university
for whom and for now I'm defining myself
as a behavioral scientist and I'm on the
way to be a real behavioural scientist
actually and first I would like to tell
talk about like what behavioral
scientists do so this is handwriting
from Aristotle and here he is defining
different animals behaviors like
courtship behavior or agonistic behavior
and here you're seeing an experimental
experiment an experiment design from a
paper this is an ethical ground for
aggressive and discipleship behaviors in
pigs so maybe you may see here like in
total they observe over 1,800 different
behaviors so what did they do here they
recorded pigs and for two hours and
later they watch the videos different
people then they made ethogram
it
means that you've watched animals then
like you define particular behavior then
you name this behaviors you would say oh
this is an aggressive behavior this is a
courtship behavior or like you would say
you want to be more specific than you
would say oh this is the attacking
behavior so you make this kind of
programs for a different animal species
and here you are seeing an example from
a zoo
so like observers sitting in front of
two pandas and watching them and making
observations and writing down what
exactly the Panda was doing like for
example ying-ying was approaching pant
pant then like so here you see like it's
written they are writing down that okay
this Panda was doing at this time then
later on they would just like define
this so this was the avoid behavior then
the animal was also ignoring the other
animal so basically like they were
watching the animals pandas and defining
their behaviors and here you're seeing
an experimental design from 1970s and
this is a closed environment and here
you see the water and also the food
source is unlimited so beginning of the
experiment they put particular number of
rodents here and they watch their
behavior after like I think like over
one year and so this space was all the
time limited and the population was
increasing after some time then they
observed like more aggressive behavior
and normally rodents will take care of
their offsprings but also after the
population increase month they just
discovered that the females are less
responsible for the offsprings they are
not caring about the feeding them then
there was also some like death Birds
then actually these named
behavioral sync also in humans they
would observe this like you would put a
particular number of humans in an
environment after a while like you would
try to make all of them happy you would
give like enough entertainment in our
food enough water but still you would
start to see different kind of behaviors
but back then whatever doing they were
just standing there and watching the
behavior of the rodents then they were
saying oh like the aggressive behavior
increased and the female care decreased
they would define this kind of steps on
the animal animals animal behavior so on
so now I show with the the animal
behavior measuring manually and what we
see here the observing animal behavior
manually would be slow and laborious and
the experimental would make subjective
decisions this would cause to difficulty
in reproducing the experiments and if
you're doing your research directly in
the nature not directly watching the
videos then you would affect actually
the animal group that you are working
with and just think that you have 200
videos then you have to watch all of
them then after a while you start to
make attention related mistakes so this
was actually happening happening to me I
was recording my pigeons then after I
don't know like one hour watching the
videos then I was just getting tired and
I was just seeing that I started to just
and not detect some particular behaviors
that I had to watch the videos again or
I was also having a collaboration
collaborator then she was also again
like checking the videos to be sure that
we are observing the similar behavior
but then the time came and I was aware
of the development in the computer
vision it takes to happen during my
master thesis so if you're not working
in a nature if you're working in a
laboratory with bursts you would use
actually this training box design
actually you would maybe know Skinner
box what you would to
would have like picking keys here and
there would be a full topper here and if
your pigeon is doing what exactly you
want like let's say you what you want
from your pigeon to pick this key then
the food would come so in the laboratory
you would have this kind of designs and
so in my experiment I was checking how
dopamine is changing pigeons behavior
about the decision decision-making so
dopamine makes you like more interested
in gaming gaming like behavior so in my
case I was giving a task to the pigeons
and it was containing like variable
delays and the fixed place we're able to
this means that so let's say I have one
picking key and I was giving a different
color let's say blue blue color is if
the pigeon pecks to blue color then
pigeon would get reward in one second or
seven seconds this was the variable this
was the gambling option for my pigeons
and if I'm giving a red color let's say
after four seconds then the pecking they
would get the reverse so this was the
fixed option so what I was expecting
if I'm giving them some upper morphine
some dopamine then they will start to
pick more the variable option which was
associated with one to seven seconds
because they would like to immediately
revert to the reward and they wouldn't
care about the 7 seconds and they was
more tend to peck T where I will option
like we observe in humans but what did
happen we injected up a morph into our
pigeons which causes the dopamine
increases and their brain and we put
them to our training box then we gave
them this variable and the fixed option
so they were picking everywhere but not
depicting his so yes
so like normally what we were doing
behind this packing his we have the
micro switches so we would count how
many times actually they are packing but
okay they are picking everywhere but we
just don't get any like one pack on this
like packing list and so also like we
were doing a sensation which means that
like we wanted to inject ten day
continuously apomorphine then we can't
like we shouldn't stop inject we
shouldn't stop like training it
otherwise we will lose the effect and we
have to get neat pigeons for the
experiment let me just say okay we are
interested in counting the pegs let's
make a design like this so we put carbon
paper and then white paper behind it
then we just cancel this design we use
card box boxes that we would get from
Ikea then we put the pigeon inside of
this box and like wait until half an
hour then check if there is any pegs on
the walls or not I'm not sure if you can
see here so it's not that observable but
like we had many pegs on these white
papers so after all then the first idea
my adviser told me okay
so you have to count this by hand okay
they were a for like papers then it was
it seemed at the beginning like
time-consuming but as a master like
student you would have more time to like
then PhD student according to your
adviser then the first idea that I had
to make this paper bigger than just
count by hand so of course it was not
possible then one of my colleague told
me that oh I can write a program with
MATLAB then we can actually count
everything with the program then the
only thing that you have to do you have
to see can this paper so I had over I
don't know 300 papers then I yeah I had
to get all of them but at the end I had
all my results like in I don't know one
hour so here you see if I would count by
hand
I would have somewhere is 8000 somewhere
I don't know somewhere here okay so for
example Apple six you have eight
thousand it means that it was it
wouldn't be possible for me to count
everything by hand also like we also
observe some like pecking patterns so I
can also explain what all these things
mean cell line means that I'm doing a
controlled injection checking if there
is any peg if I'm injecting something as
a control then I'm injecting upper
morphine for one day two day three day
than the a
they then again after up a morphine
injection finish I'm checking the said
on condition again then after like of
abortion injections I'm seeing like over
and total like two thousand packing so
this was the first time that I was a
bear of the developments in the computer
vision then when I started my PhD are
like I switched more behavioral
experiments the this experiment is about
body embodiment in pigeons which means
that like pigeon has the wings then also
defeat but if you attach something else
to the pigeon what pigeon will to if you
are putting it to the next pair mental
design in my experimental design what I
had I had a feeder here at the entrance
of the labyrinth and also I had a feeder
at the end of the Reverend and here also
like I had the gap and this gap
decreased until the end of the
deliverance and I maybe you see here a
red plastic arm but he you see here a
little bit longer I attached this like
plastic arms to see how they are moving
in this labyrinth like if they are slow
if I'm like decreasing the size of the
gaps if they are okay after some time if
they are getting used to having
something attached on their body but the
real reason that I'm doing this
experiment I would like to see if they
can use this attached arms to obtain a
food if they can so an experimental
design with this attached item but for
this I would like to first define which
a length of plastic arm that they I
should attached and they would be
comfortable so I was trying like two
centimeter four centimeter six twenty
meter and actively hi as I tried 12
centimeter which actually they failed
they couldn't walk like from here then
they were just stopping there they were
only eating food from here and not going
to other like feeder then the first idea
was I had to watch all the videos to
decide the arm length for each pigeons
so this is again like time consuming but
luckily at the beginning of the X
experiment what we did we used
direct pigeon clothing to etch the
attach this plastic arms so every time
when I was putting the pigeon they had
to wear just like read a lot to like
have this like plastic attachment on
their body then we decided instead of
watching all the videos and analyzing
everything by hands
let's do color tracking and like to
define which pigeon is comfortable which
length of arm so then we did our pigeon
tracker and what we did here we did like
convert our frames to HSV color frame
then the mask we create the mask and if
we found the contoured and the tracked
object defined as the like the biggest
culture is defined as the detract object
actually I can show you an example here
so here we are like converting our frame
to HSV color dimension then here you see
the map and you see here are like the
red cloth that pigeon was wearing the
biggest culture then like we like made a
sort of like rectangle around this like
contoured and we track this point
exactly in our experimental design but
what would be interesting for me like
maybe you may see here to see like okay
here pigeon is little bit having problem
because here we had to feed there then
walking here again having some problem
but still walking and here the smallest
gap its pigeon again like a suffering
like suffering means that like going
back and forward counteract Li like walk
through the wall but here but at the end
it's going to here to eat from the foot
so for me I would say that this pigeon
is comfortable with this length of the
arm so this was the main reason that I
was doing this color tracking so still
we are working on the experiment for
some pigeons we define that 10
centimeter of arm length
is still okay that they can like they
can walk through the labyrinth but not
for all the pigeons so still we have
lights we have like six pigeons that we
want to try this experiment and to go
further to teach them how to use this
like arm to obtain food so it will turn
to a robotic arm project at the end so
this is our like real plan for this
experiment in my second experiment I'm
looking mirror selfie cognition so here
you see a magpie and like so make pies
pest is like mirror selfie combination
test and here you are seeing one kind of
end and they're observing that when they
have their mirrors have image they show
different behavior than having another
and two on the next compartment and here
you see cleaner whereas fish so like
this fish actually kind of a social fish
would like to clean the other fish or
other bigger fish from the parasites or
from some like dirt and they also pass
this like mirror selfie combination and
here you see the chimps and here you see
an Asian elephant that they also pass
this mirrors have recognition so mirror
selfie cognition I can explain how they
are doing this you mark the animal from
a point that they can't see directly
themselves like they can't see this like
a marking point on their body but if you
put them in front of the mirror then
they would show a tendency to reach that
point try to play with it or try to
clean it and you would also see that
like they are trying to see the hidden
parts of their body and so these are the
behaviors that you would say this animal
pest is mirror self a cognition test so
it's also a characteristic of higher
intelligence but limited to FeO animal
species but the problem is like you see
many different kind of species here so
all the time they were applying the same
methylation for all this animals then at
the end they were making
a conclusion okay this animal has a
miracle coke nation they pass the
marking test
so okay marking this of course is easier
for a chimp to pass the marking test
because like they can actually directly
point there like a hand or they are
extra meter to this mark point like but
to applying the same metal for a fish
for and then for magpie it's a little
bit like a not favor actually
so in our experimental design what we
thought okay so already the pigeons
failed in the marketing test but we were
not sure exactly what they are seeing as
a mirror or self image then we decided
to check their eating behavior in front
of their mirror image or in front of
another pigeon so what we did here we
had like mirror approaching condition
which means that we put a mirror we put
the food in front of the mirror and let
the pigeon eat from the feeder in front
of the mirror and then we put another
pigeon through the next compartment then
put all the food in front of this
stranger pigeon then check their
behavior have their eating in front of
another pigeon so this was these were
the approaching conditions and also we
had away conditions which means that
people to food on the opposite side of
mirror or on the opposite side of the
stranger pigeon so first like we didn't
think about doing any tracking we wanted
to check the basic behavior the first
behavior was approaching behavior which
means that how long it takes for the
pigeon to reach the feeder when the food
is in front of the like a mirror or in
front of the stranger pigeon or here
like opposite side of the like other
pigeon or about the side of the mirror
image what we observed here like time
latency didn't have like didn't show
significant effect especially in like
mirror approaching condition and like a
situation approaching we were away and
stranger away so here we did actually
one more experiment we wanted to see the
habituation effect of the habituation
effect of the mirror and to see if we
are not habituating the pigeon
to the mirror then there it takes longer
for them to reach the feather then we
also check the total number of pegs to
the feeder and also we didn't observe
any like significant effect between the
different conditions but if you want to
publish something it's not just nice to
show this like to conditions like time
latency or like the total number of the
pecks you have to show of different
behavior behavior critic criterias but
our patients didn't show like an
aggressive behavior or any like
interesting behavior that we would
observe in different animals then we
decided to do deep learning actually
with our pigeons so we use this open
source program the plop cut then what we
did we create the project and extract
extract the frames from different videos
then the level which points of the
pigeons we would like to track then we
train our deep neural deep neural
network then later we check our network
performance we check the different
frames from different videos if there is
any like miss detection then we had to
correct we had to do the correction then
after being sure that like all the
videos has the right tracking points
then we just like analyze all the videos
with our trained example then we plot
our results so actually I can show you a
small video how it works so you see that
so we are tracking the head we are
tricking the wigs wings we are tracking
the body we are tracking the tail so I
don't have that much time so therefore
I'm speeding up and then so then we
check the activity rate and also the
body posture but the posture means that
like the if the pigeons are like turning
their body or the head to the mirror or
they are just like turning back to the
mirror or like they are more interested
to watching the stranger pigeon or like
or they are like kind of don't care
about having a change of pigeon on the
neck
comparing what we found that like the
when this there is another pigeon on the
next compartment they are more
interested in to watch the stranger
pigeon compared to the mirror watching
the winner image and in the activity
rate we actually observe higher activity
rate in the stranger approaching
condition compared to the mirror
approaching condition which means that
when there is a so strange opinion on
the next in the next compartment they
are kind of like excited and they are
like walking around and trying to
observe what the other pigeon is doing
but in the mineral approaching condition
they were basically if like frozen and
not doing anything significant then what
we concluded that the approaching
approaching the stranger condition
produce more feeder oriented behavior
than the approaching the mirror
condition and the time they tended to
reach the feeder was increased when the
field was placed in front of the mirror
rather than the in front of the stranger
and the activity rate was decreased in
the mirror associated conditions
compared to the stranger associated
conditions and we conclude that like
these mirrors have a cognition is not a
binary test like you may not say that or
like this animal has a mirror Safa
calculation this animal doesn't have as
mirrors - cognition we think that there
are some steps in the between and we
should actually eating about different
methodology to check the different
species to conclude this near cipher
cognition subject so here I would like
to thank to my pigeons and my professor
professor owner Gunther Kuhn and my
colleagues for asymmetry and heavenly
tech so thank you for your listening
thank you
[Applause]
you have five minutes for questions any
questions so I have one is it possible
or have you ever experiment in the
outside where is less controlled
environment for the pigeons so are
actually next plan
one of next plan is checking collective
behavior on pigeons we have this big
heavy air instead pigeons actually
walking freely and there are over 880
pigeons inside of a beacon aviary then
we would like to trick them and also to
see that if they show the collective
behaviors like the other social like
animals or birds show so we have this
kind of plans yes like and also develop
cut the program that I show you it's
actually applicable for this like
collective behavior stuff thank you very
much just have a small question what was
the objective of the first experiments
what would you try by the embodiment
sorry the morphine order by the
embodiment the one when you were so like
so we have the Leblon to see if pigeon
can navigate itself like like the same
without having this plastic arm attached
on their body so like as they as a human
if I attach you something on your body
and if I'm putting it a narrow
experimental room then it you need some
time to get used to having this plastic
arm to navigate yourself but as a human
your cognitive abilities are better than
the pigeon Stein you would you wouldn't
have problem but in my case like first
pigeon would be shocked at having
something attached on their body but
still they know that there is food at
the end of the labyrinth and they have
to navigate themselves to end of the
labyrinth so but then I'm checking how
long it takes for the pigeons to be
comforted always attached with this
attached arms and
later on if they are comfortable let's
say with eight centimeter this attache
item I would like to see if they can
also use this attached item as as like
as their body part like for obtaining
but food from in a different
experimental design so like I would like
to see that they can think that now
these are this arm is like belongs to my
body and I can use this to obtain food
any other question
cool yeah you mentioned about behavioral
science having this problem where it can
be quite subjective and I think through
our history there's many things that we
were sure with the way things were and
then discovered later not quite true so
do you feel like using computer vision
it's a way that we can start to have a
clearer view with less subjectivity or
do you see still problems now the first
like so the computer vision is like kind
of decreasing the time that we are
spending to analyze the data but the
second work will start soon that like we
actually should make a difference at Oh
grams again with this computer vision
data so like for example in my case I
tracked the wings and I would say that
okay the pigeon is so that the wings are
moving a lot it means that pigeon is
doing something like interesting at that
point and I'm checking the video then I
would say okay this is the attacking
like still there is a lot to do that to
define different like behavioral
criterias different ethogram from
different species so there a lot to do
just this is now decreasing the time
that we are spending to analyze all the
videos instead of like watching 200
videos then I'm just like running my
program then the videos are analyzed
then if I'm seeing some interesting
points and I'm going back to that that
video that specific part and I'm saying
ok now this behavior is like related
with courtship or discipline haver is
related to attacking
or aggressiveness so yes okay oh so
sorry been a killjoy but we do have only
like a V okay so the upper morphine
experiment I had 16 pigeons then and
despite the embodiment now I have 12
pigeons and the meter experiment I have
8 such Ranger 8 meter pigeons but if you
want to publish something like
convenient then it's better to have like
more than 8 pigeons so especially for
the behavioral experiment so in the
mirror experiment I used the same gender
because as a mirror image they would
actually like see the same gender so
then I was using the same but for
apomorphine
or for the second party embodiment the
experiment like I didn't like think
about the general stuff but it's a good
question for the member experiment so
this was actually the main concern of us
we wanted to be sure that this stranger
pigeon on the next compartment also has
the same gender
that would be experimented by the
experimentation so this is our not
having more time so let's thanks very
much nezam for the talk
[Applause]